pero cada vez más cerca de las
exportaciones de los cereales ucranianos
bloqueados por la guerra en estambul
abrió oficialmente el centro de
coordinación conjunta que supervisará
que los granos lleguen a su destino e
inspeccionar a los barcos en busca de
armas prohibidas al entrar y salir del
mar negro
el acuerdo cubre el grano y derivados de
alimento y también los fertilizantes
esto es lo que la iniciativa cubre hasta
donde deriva el acuerdo y cuantos más
productos se puedan exportar eso está
por determinar
[Música]
el pacto mediado por naciones unidas y
ankara abrió la puerta para el
funcionamiento de este centro en
estambul donde trabajan 20 funcionarios
de ucrania rusia turquía en la onu
de acuerdo a las condiciones actuales se
ha hecho necesario establecer un
corredor marítimo para la entrega segura
de 25 millones de toneladas de grano que
esperan en los puertos ucranianos ser
kirchner
sobre todo hombres pero en terreno hay
incertidumbre con el humo a lo lejos
causado por los bombardeos los
agricultores en los campos de trigo del
sur de ucrania recogen sus cosechas
los agricultores están asumiendo los
riesgos ya que existe la posibilidad de
bombardeos pero siguen cosechando porque
de lo contrario será aún peor en
invierno hay algunas zonas en las que no
se puede cosechar cerca de la región de
mi cola la mayoría de los campos se han
quemado por el bloqueo a las entregas de
cereales por la guerra causó un aumento
mundial de precios y se prevé que lleve
a millones de personas a sus hambre
aguda